We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is not 99% of its bowl, but I am Roman Mars. So I created a secret side project podcast with a friend of mine. The goal was to take some of my anxiety about the political news and turn it into something constructive and fun and interesting and share it with people.
我们得到了加 戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食物、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加 戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这不是 99% 的碗，我是罗曼·马斯。所以我跟一个朋友创建了一个秘密的副业播客。目标是将我对政治新闻的一些焦虑转化为建设性、有趣且好玩的东西，并与大家分享。
And I hope you like it, I hope you subscribe, I hope you tell all your friends, let's send it to the top of the charts, that would be nice. I want to take all of this energy and do something good, like learning the US Constitution. So here's the introductory episode, thanks. The whole idea for this series came from a tweet. It was by Elizabeth Jo, she's a professor at the UC Davis School of Law, and I know her personally because our kids go to the same elementary school. Elizabeth's tweet read, and I'm paraphrasing a little bit so it sounds better when I read it out loud.
希望你们会喜欢，希望你们订阅，希望你们告诉所有的朋友，让我们把它推上排行榜的顶端，那就太好了。我想把所有的这些精力都用在做一件好事上，比如学习美国宪法。这里是序曲集，谢谢。这个系列的整个灵感来自于一条推特。发推的是伊丽莎白·乔，她是加 戴维斯分校法学院的教授，我个人认识她，因为我们的孩子上同一所小学。伊丽莎白推特上的内容是这样的，我稍微改写了一下，这样我大声读出来会更好听一点。
Teaching constitutional law in 2017 means glancing at Twitter every five minutes before a class First I laughed then I retweeted it and then I wondered What does that mean exactly? I mean I kind of have an idea what constitutional law is It's a class that's sometimes called the structural aspect of the Constitution that is the aforementioned law professor Elizabeth Cho So I talk about things like the separation of powers. What are the different powers of the president versus Congress? I also talk about federalism, so how much power Congress has as opposed to state legislatures? It's nothing but it's usually a requirement if you're going to be a lawyer.
在 2017 年教宪法意味着在上课前每五分钟瞄一眼推特。一开始我笑了，然后我转发了，接着我开始琢磨：这到底是什么意思？我的意思是，我大概知道宪法是什么。这是一门有时被称为宪法结构方面的课程，也就是前面提到的法学教授伊丽莎白·乔。所以我讲的是诸如权力分立之类的事情。总统和国会分别有哪些不同的权力？我还谈到了联邦主义，即国会相对于州议会拥有多少权力？这没什么，但如果你想当一名律师，这通常是必修课。
It's a class I love teaching a lot. I admit that not every student loves it. And I can see why. For example, the very first case I assign on the first day of class every year is a case that was written in 1803. It's called Marbury versus Madison. It's a big deal and we'll talk about it at some point.
这是一门我很喜欢教的课。我承认并不是每个学生都喜欢它。我也能理解。例如，我每年在开学第一天布置的第一个案件是 1803 年写的一个案件。它被称为马伯里诉麦迪逊案。这是一件大事，我们会在某个时候讨论它。
But all you need to know right now is that the first sentence of that case is 60 words long. And the verb comes in the middle, so it's pretty dry, but this year has been a little bit different. And why is it different? Oh, you know why. This is what Trump can teach us about Con Law, an ongoing series of indefinite length where we take the extreme actions of the Chief Executive of the United States
但你现在只需要知道的是，那个案件的第一句话长达 60 个词。而动词在中间，所以它相当枯燥，但今年有点不同。为什么不同？噢，你们知道为什么。这就是特朗普能教给我们的关于宪法的事，这是一个长度不定的持续系列节目，我们将美国行政首长的极端行为
and channel that chaos into learning our Constitution like we never have before. I'm your fellow student and host, Roman Mars. Coming up, we're going to law school, but in a fun way, and it's meant for everybody. But first, we gotta pay some bills. It's still gonna be cheaper than law school. But first, we gotta pay some bills. It's still gonna be cheaper than law school. Support for Trump Con Law comes from Squarespace. As you can tell from the existence of this side project podcast of mine, I like to take on new creative projects just because I can't help myself.
转化为动力，以前所未有的方式学习我们的宪法。我是你的同学兼主持人，罗曼·马斯。接下来，我们要去法学院了，但以一种有趣的方式，而且它是为所有人准备的。但首先，我们得付点账单。它仍然会比法学院便宜。但首先，我们得付点账单。它仍然会比法学院便宜。《特朗普宪法课》得到了 Squarespace 的赞助。正如你从这个副业播客的存在所能看出的，我喜欢承担新的创意项目，因为我情不自禁。
If you're about to embark on a new project, you should announce it to the world with a cool website from Squarespace. Their award-winning templates are the simplest and most beautiful way to present your ideas online. Even someone like me who has no business coding at all can create a beautiful website with Squarespace's all-in-one platform. There's nothing to install, patch, or upgrade. Ever.
如果你正要开启一个新的项目，你应该用 Squarespace 的炫酷网站向全世界宣告。他们屡获殊荣的模板是在网上展示你的想法最简单、最美观的方式。像我这样完全不懂代码的人也能用 Squarespace 的一体化平台创建一个漂亮的网站。没有什么需要安装、打补丁或升级的。永远没有。
For free trial and 10% off your first purchase, visit squarespace.com slash con law. That's all one word. That's squarespace.com slash con law. So the bread and butter of law professors are hypotheticals. Professors love hypotheticals, crazy things that happen, that they sort of think about in their minds, what if? What could happen? And so it's the sort of thing that is not realistic always,
欲享受免费试用并在首次购买时享受 90% 的折扣，请访问 squarespace.com/conlaw。全都是一个词。即 squarespace.com/conlaw。所以法学教授的看家本领是假想情况。教授们喜欢假想情况，那些在他们脑海中琢磨的、疯狂的事情：如果会怎样？可能会发生什么？所以这是那种并非总是现实的事情，
but it's a way to get law students to think about what are the limits of law. For example, here's a crazy hypothetical. Could a former president sue a sitting president for libel for making false statements about him? I'm sure you're like, well, that's impossible, but it is possible. In this new reality, that's not a crazy hypothetical. President Trump tweeted that President Obama had illegally tapped his phones during the election process. He said it was at the level of Watergate, and he called him a bad or sick guy.
但这是一种让法学院学生思考法律界限是什么的方法。例如，这里有一个疯狂的假想情况。前任总统可以因为现任总统发表关于他的虚假言论而起诉他诽谤吗？我确信你们会觉得，嗯，这不可能，但这是可能的。在这个新现实中，这不是一个疯狂的假想情况。特朗普总统发推说奥巴马总统在选举过程中非法窃听了他的电话。他说这达到了水门事件的水平，并称他为一个坏蛋或有病的人。
It doesn't appear to have any proof, but that's what he tweeted. And this new window into the mind of Trump has changed the way Professor Joe prepares for class. Before this year, when I prepared to teach each day's class for a constitutional law, typically I would read what I had assigned, look through my notes from the previous year, go teach class. Her procedure is a little bit different this year. This year I had a little ongoing note to myself, do not go to class until I have checked whether
这似乎没有任何证据，但这就是他在推特上发的内容。这个了解特朗普内心世界的新窗口改变了乔教授备课的方式。在这之前的一年里，当我准备每一天的宪法课时，通常我会阅读我布置的内容，浏览我前一年的笔记，然后去上课。她今年的程序有点不同。今年我给自己留了一个小便条，在确认
the president has tweeted. If the president has tweeted, screenshot the tweets and discuss with class. So when Roman, when you brought up the idea of having some basic explanations about Conla, I thought, what a terrific idea. There are so many constitutional issues that this presidency has brought up. Whether you're testing mathematical models or automobile crashes, I think you will learn a lot about something by testing the extremes. So I like this idea that maybe we have a president who's kind of stressed testing the Constitution, really giving us a sense of what are the limits of each of the
总统是否发了推特之前，不要去上课。如果总统发了推特，就把推特截图并在课堂上讨论。所以当罗曼你提出对宪法有一些基本解释的想法时，我想，这真是个绝妙的主意。这个总统任期引发了太多的宪法问题。无论你是在测试数学模型还是汽车碰撞，我认为通过测试极端情况，你都会对某事有很多了解。所以我喜欢这个想法，也许我们有一个有点在对宪法进行压力测试的总统，真正让我们感受到他对宪法中似乎正在受到挑战的每一个
different provisions that he seems to be challenging in the Constitution. And that's really important because it turns out it's forcing us to think about things and wonder, well, do we have answers to some of these questions? For example, when can Trump treat the presidency like the apprentice and declare you're fired? When can the administration declare it's going to cut off funds to sanctuary cities? When the president talks about so-called courts, should we be worried about that? Yes, you should be worried that's solid, yes, but we'll do an episode about it nonetheless. What about impeachment? Is that going to happen? I think it's actually practically pretty unlikely,
不同条款的界限在哪里。这真的很重要，因为事实证明它迫使我们思考并怀疑，嗯，我们对其中一些问题有答案吗？例如，特朗普什么时候可以像《学徒》节目那样对待总统职位并宣布“你被解雇了”？行政部门什么时候可以宣布将切断对庇护城市的资金？当总统谈到所谓法院时，我们应该担心吗？是的，你应当担心，这是肯定的，但我们无论如何都会做一个关于它的节目。弹劾呢？这会发生吗？我认为实际上这在实践中不太可能，
but everybody's talking and wondering about this portion of the Constitution, so it's important to understand what it's about. Maybe even more interesting is that we're dusting off parts of the Constitution that people hardly even considered in 200 years. So for example, uh, present Trump just went overseas. He got a gold medal while he was in Saudi Arabia. Can he keep that shiny gold medal? Is that the kind of thing that's barred by the emoluments clause of the Constitution? Or what about owning the Trump hotel or property in other countries? Plus, there's this hardly considered part of the Constitution that liberals are salivating over. Could a president be declared unfit to serve and then removed from office? That's the 25th amendment. These questions don't generally make it into
但每个人都在谈论和思考宪法的这部分内容，所以了解它是关于什么的很重要。可能更有趣的是，我们正在拂去人们在 200 年里几乎从未考虑过的宪法部分的灰尘。例如，呃，特朗普总统刚刚去了海外。他在沙特阿拉伯获得了一枚金牌。他能保留那枚闪亮的金牌吗？那是宪法薪酬条款所禁止的那类事情吗？或者拥有特朗普酒店或在其他国家的财产呢？此外，还有一个几乎不被考虑的宪法部分，自由主义者对此垂涎三尺。一个总统会被宣布不适合任职然后被免职吗？这就是第 25 条修正案。这些问题通常不会进入
the basic constitutional law textbooks. Because really no one has cared about them before. They're not relevant, that's the basic answer. It's kind of relevant now. So this is a real opportunity. I think when it comes to the Constitution, this should be a moment to care a lot about the Constitution. And it's not an onerous task. It's short.
基础宪法法教科书。因为真的以前没有人关心过它们。它们不相关，这是基本答案。现在有点相关了。所以这是一个真正的机会。我认为当谈到宪法时，这应该是一个非常关心宪法的时候。而且这不是一项繁重的任务。它很短。
It's less than 5,000 words. You know, we're both Californians here, so I'll give you an example of the California Constitution. The California Constitution is 100 pages long. It's one of the longest in the world. So by contrast, the federal Constitution, you can read in one sitting. It's pretty easy. It's also a remarkably stable document. The federal Constitution's only been changed or amended, 27 times, and really only 17 times, since the first 10, the Bill of Rights were erratified very shortly after the original constitution.
它不到 5000 个字。你知道，我们俩都是加州人，所以我给你举一个加州宪法的例子。加州宪法有 100 页长。它是世界上最长的宪法之一。相比之下，你可以一次读完联邦宪法。这相当容易。这也是一份非常稳定的文件。联邦宪法只被修改或修正过 27 次，自最初的十条（即《权利法案》）在最初宪法通过后不久被批准以来，实际上只修改了 17 次。
California Constitution, we love changing stuff, we get tired of it. We've actually changed our state constitution over 500 times. California is stuff to cliche. So what's my conclusion here? It turns out that in 2017, I've decided that Trump can teach you a lot about Conlaw. So we're going to learn the Constitution together because of Trump, because I need something to hold on to, and the Constitution is the life raft our forefathers gave us. And damn it, I'm going to learn how it works. A preview of what's coming up this season on Trump Con Law after this.
加州宪法，我们喜欢改变东西，我们对此感到厌倦。我们实际上已经修改了我们的州宪法 500 多次。加州简直是老生常谈。那么我这里的结论是什么？事实证明，在 2017 年，我决定特朗普能教给你很多关于宪法的知识。所以我们要因为特朗普一起学习宪法，因为我需要一些东西来坚持，而宪法是我们先辈留给我们的救生筏。该死的，我要学会它是如何运作的。接下来的节目预告，本季关于特朗普宪法的节目，稍后播出。
Are you hiring? Are you the president? Invoking Article 2 Section 2 clause 2 of the U.S. Constitution? Well with Zip Recruiter, you can post your job to 100 plus job sites with one click. Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job better than anyone else. Find out today why Zip Recruiter has been used by businesses of all sizes to find the most qualified job candidates with immediate results. And right now, my listeners, presidents and non-presidents alike can post jobs on Zip Recruiter for free.
你在招聘吗？你是总统吗？援引美国宪法第二条第二款第二句？好吧，通过 Zip Recruiter，只需轻轻一点击，你就可以将你的工作发布到 100 多个求职网站上。然后，他们强大的技术可以比其他任何人都更有效地将合适的人匹配到你的工作。今天就来了解为什么 Zip Recruiter 一直被各种规模的企业用来寻找最合格的求职者并取得立竿见影的效果。现在，我的听众们，无论是总统还是非总统，都可以在 Zip Recruiter 上免费发布工作。
Go to ziprecruiter.com slash conlaw. That's ziprecruiter.com slash conlaw. This season on what Trump can teach us about Con Law. Think of a few things that have made the headlines. So-called courts, the president refers to the judiciary as so-called, he really raises a question about judicial legitimacy. That's going to take us back in time to Youngstown, Ohio, President Truman and the Korean War. President Trump has threatened sanctuary cities. Why is that even an issue for the federal government to talk about?
请访问 ziprecruiter.com/conlaw。即 ziprecruiter.com/conlaw。本季《特朗普能教给我们关于宪法的什么》。想想几个登上头条的新闻。所谓的法院，总统将司法机构称为所谓的，他真的对司法合法性提出了质疑。这将把我们带回到过去，回到扬斯敦、俄亥俄州、杜鲁门总统和朝鲜战争。特朗普总统威胁了庇护城市。为什么这甚至是联邦政府需要讨论的问题？
That's because of the spending clause. Trump wants to build a border wall, and we're still not sure who's going to pay for it. But one thing that's absolutely clear is that if you're going to build a physical wall all along the Southern United States, you have to take people's private property. And that involves the takings clause.
那是因为支出条款。特朗普想要修建一处边境墙，而我们仍然不确定谁来为此买单。但有一点绝对清楚，如果你要在美国南部沿线修建一堵实体墙，你就必须夺取人们的私人财产。这涉及征用条款。
We are probably gonna get a lot stricter with the border in all kinds of places, not just with the physical border of the United States, but also at international airports. And many more people are raising concerns that their cell phones and laptops are getting looked at by border patrol. What happens when you are asked to provide the contents of your cell phone or laptop?
我们可能在各个地方对边境采取更严格的措施，不仅是美国的实体边境，而且在国际机场也是如此。越来越多的人开始担心他们的手机和笔记本电脑正受到边境巡逻队的检查。当你被要求提供手机或笔记本电脑的内容时会发生什么？
Why can that happen? Can it happen? And that has to do with the fourth amendments so-called border doctrine. So every week, I'm inviting you and Elizabeth Jo over to my house to teach us these topics and so, so many more on. What Trump can teach us about Con Law? It's gonna be fun and you're gonna get smarter and be a better citizen.
为什么会发生这种情况？这能发生吗？这与第四修正案所谓的边境学说有关。所以每周，我都邀请你和伊丽莎白·乔来到我家，教我们这些主题以及更多更多关于：特朗普能教给我们关于宪法的什么？这会很有趣，你会变得更聪明，成为一个更好的公民。
Bring the kids they're gonna like it too. Subscribe now in Apple Podcasts, Radio Public or wherever you get your podcasts. The first full episode is already there, it's waiting for you. Go to trumpconlaw.com for a link. This show is produced by Elizabeth Cho and me Roman Mars. All the music and trumpcon laws provided by Doom Tree Records, the Midwest Hip Hop Collective. The two big takeaway lessons from this show are learn the Constitution and buy Doom Tree Records because both will make your life 100% better.
带上孩子们，他们也会喜欢的。现在就在 Apple Podcasts、Radio Public 或你获取播客的任何地方订阅。第一个完整版节目已经在那里，正等着你。请访问 trumpconlaw.com 获取链接。本节目由伊丽莎白·乔和我罗曼·马斯制作。所有的音乐和特朗普宪法相关的音乐都由中西部嘻哈集体 Doom Tree Records 提供。本节目的两个重大收获是学习宪法和购买 Doom Tree Records，因为这两者都会让你的生活变好 100%。
The tracks this week were from Sims, Dessa, and Laserbeak. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX. Find out more at radiotopia.fm. Radio Topia. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周的曲目来自 Sims、Dessa 和 Laserbeak。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的自豪成员。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。Radio Topia。来自 PRX。你 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。